merci bravo et voilà donc maintenant
j'espère serre est prêt à répondre à mes
appels alors est donc sacré quatrième
dauphine 1987 nous vous écoutons
autrement dit celle qui occupe la 5e
place alors nous avons les résultats
exacts cas 4e 4e dauphine quatrième
dauphine c'est la noce et le lille
métropole lille métropole caroline lille
métropole quatrième dauphine qui va
recevoir son écharpe des mains de miss
france 86 et qui va les prendre sa place
sur le podium au pied des marches ou via
monte dans quelques instants de miss
france 87 alors europe numéro un voulez
vous nous indiquez très vite alors que
les impositions encore bis métropole
quand même qu elle est la dauphine
numéro 3 la troisième boucle
la troisième dauphine troisième dauphine
c'est c'est triste elle attendait parce
que là on a enlevé cette femme petite
erreur oui là la troisième dauphine
c'est la camargue
stéphane brachet ne vous trompez pas
c'est très grave
certains certains viennent d'apporter le
petit espère que vous êtes entourés de
nombreux comptable expert experts merci
experts voient la deuxième dauphine
2 / attendez attendez on applaudit
maintenant qu'elle a ceint l'écharpé de
3e dauphine miss camargue
voici la deuxième dauphine
qui est dauphine troisième dauphine
pardon 2 est deuxième dauphine
complètement troublé parce que là je
sais pas si tu manques est ce que vous
seriez c était comme nous à côté
oui sauriez-vous deuxième dauphine donc
c'est là la réunion avec joël ramia
deuxième
est ce que vous êtes sûr de votre
classement je vous avais dit tout à
l'heure que les parisiens étaient plus
se tourner vers la chaleur
attendez attendez ou est-ce que j'en
suis 2e dauphine deuxième dauphine
qu'est-ce qui se passe deuxième couche
qu'est-ce qui est la nôtre miss elle se
fâche tabac une miss proteste elle dit
que pourtant pour la première fois c'est
le public qui vote si personne d'autre
miss réunion par conséquent deuxième
dauphine tel est le verdict de nos amis
qui ont voté par milliers en europe
numéro un ça n'est pas semble-t-il la
faveur du public mais qu'est ce que vous
voulez vous êtes sûr de votre résultat
mon cher céleste n'ont donc n'était pas
d'erreur attendez je pense que ce
chiffre d'affaires 2010 erreur c'est
très très grave
attendez on refait on le fait parce que
la ville est hockey e céleste attendez
attendez attendez 30 ans bredouille
écusson oui exact 4 seles oui je suis là
je suis là attendait effectivement on a
peut-être quelques mairies quand même
des gens qui sont capables de l'europe
et oui de faire des comptes exacts
attendait le numéro 5 et est attribué à
qui amuse réunion et coûteux non diarra
est en train de mettre est bien là on
n'y a aucun problème là
ou est ce que nous en sommes attendez
nous avons donc donné la 4e' de la 5e et
4e dauphine la troisième dauphine la
deuxième
enfin vous n'êtes pas entouré de gens
capables de faire des comptes sérieux
monsieur seles ça me paraît quand même
très grave
la deuxième dauphine on est en mesure de
l'affirmer complètement d'une façon très
sincère c'est joël ramia de la réunion
2e dauphine
c'est à dire qui est classée troisième
dans votre classement attendait
effectivement jeu c'est là où je butais
la non en fait il ya une grosse erreur
la trois olala ça y est nous y sommes
laquelle à petra vous êtes en train de
nous mettre mon chien écoutez moi
d'actes l'an passé à l'on pouvait faire
confiance en europe
en europe on peut faire confiance
complètement perdus alors que finalement
on vous a ramené un vote à cinq
candidates pourquoi vous vous trompiez
c'est quand même assez grave la deuxième
dauphine et la camargue avec stéphane
brachet deuxième dauphine
nous y sommes ça y est et écoutez je
vais vous aider c est parce qu il ya
quelque chose qui va pas oui ok cassis
5e 5e c'est lille métropole qui est
classé quatrième
c'est la grande motte avec grande motte
qui est classée troisième c'est la
camargue qui donc deuxième dauphine
camargue et non pas réunion c'est bien
cela c'est ça tout à fait bravo merci
pour nous avoir fait des émotions et
j'ai cru que nous allions avoir une
émeute ici alors 2 3e classe i troisième
est étendu à une deuxième dauphine la
grande la camarde principe maintenant
première dauphine c'est-à-dire classé
12e eh bien ce n'est qu'une juste
récompense pour la réunion puisque les
premières dauphines la réunion la
réunion 1ère dauphine
voulez vous mesdemoiselles je m'excuse
de mettre un petit peu énervé mais ça
n'allait pas du tout du côté d'europe
voulez vous prendre vos places s'il vous
plaît au pied du podium renesmée loisel
la mise au point
et
y'a une des parties ne sais pas pourquoi
furieuse
et donc par conséquent élue miss france
1987 europe avec 42% points 2 des voix
nathalie marquay sur l'alsace miss
alsace
miss france
l'annexion meuleuse voix l'élection au
le spacebook que ce n'est pas très
gentil
ici dans un vérifie qu parce que je
trouve qu à vis alsace et ravissante et
je voudrais bien quand même que même si
miss réunion semblait ici dans cette
salle de 3 400 personnes remporté les
suffrages n'avons pas aller contre des
milliers de voix de auditeurs et des
téléspectateurs qui ont téléphoné europe
et qui ont sacré nice alsace
miss france 87
voilà nous allons apporter cette pièce
compter que nous pourrons rien trader à
paris est un monsieur pierrine vous
voulez vous la monter là-haut à côté de
miss france car maintenant on peut me
laisser les photographes intervenir
maintenant vous pouvez arriver messieurs
les photographes pour prendre miss
france
comme il ya une dauphine qui est parti
je propose de la remplacer par miss
lorraine avec miss lorraine
mr quatrième dauphine si vous voulez
vous revenir puisque l'autre a considéré
qu'elle n'était pas digne d'être
dauphiné qu'elle voulait peut-être être
miss france
voilà alors je voudrais simplement
maintenant vous remercier tous et toutes
j'espère céleste que vous étiez de ce
résultat final quand même
so lu ment sur glee c'est un peu dommage
que nous soyons comme on dit amélie les
crayons avec les premières deuxièmes
extra et dope insee toujours pardon je
vous entends très mal si on n'a pas
l'habitude d'élire une miss france ici
oui mais enfin vous avez peut-être quand
même l'habitude de lire des chiffres
parce que c'est pas le premier sondage
que vous faites et je trouve un petit
peu désolant ce qui s'est passé mais
enfin tant pis ce qui prouve que
tournait toujours pas tous parfaits
quand on commence une première fois
c'était pourtant simple on avait ramené
alors je voudrais que vous à policiers
le dernière fois ici au studio 15 des
buttes chaumont à paris et partout des
miss france et leur mobile et ses
dauphines c'est derrière miss france
miss alsace miss réunion et sa première
dauphine miss grandes bottes sa deuxième
miss camargue ce troisième et la
quatrième n'est pas alors c'est sur ces
images que je vais vous donner
rendez-vous à mellac esponde et monsieur
thierry peuvent à la montée alors
mademoiselle mademoiselle miss alsace
voulez-vous venir près de la pièce
montée découpez la première part de
gâteau c'est sur ces images que nous
allons nous séparer
pour ma part je vous donne rendez vous
le 21 février le 21 janvier pardon à
avoriaz où nous retrouverons
traditionnellement notre émission c'est
aujourd'hui demain avec son côté
fantastique puisque ce sera dans le kop
du festival du film du même nom
ce sera je peux vous le promettre une
soirée fantastique
celle de ce soir a eu quelques
soubresauts
nous avons eu quelques ennuis au niveau
du vote
cela dit je pense que c'est tout à fait
définitif n'est ce pas mon cher et l'est
oui pas de problème
problème en alsace qui couteau à ma
tranche de gâteau 1987 qui est sacrée
miss france c'est bien miss réunion que
sa première dauphine
on peut dire sa vie sereine et c'est
bien sûr que nous avons récoltées de
quoi ouvrir les portes de sa maison à
l'abbé pierre et croyez moi finalement
c'était bien ça le plus important
bonsoir à tous et bonne année encore au
21 janvier pour notre prochaine émission
au revoir à tous